that's what disturbs me more than
anything else is that it's the arrogance
combined with the
being naive the naive to think okay
here's what's going on iraq
look
we know that saddam's not a good guy we
can probably create some kind of a good
ally there and we can probably just turn
this into a democracy because we like
democracy and we you know we like it and
all those people must want to be free
too and we've got people that came from
iraq or that are in iraq that say hell
yeah we want to be free so cool
let's invade and in their minds it plays
out hey it's going to be like the first
gulf war it'll take us you know a couple
weeks then we'll start to we'll get rid
of the bath party we'll establish we'll
start building walmarts right that i
think that that's what they thought more
than anything else probably
and it's just it's just an arrogant it's
just arrogance it's well it's not just
arrogance it's arrogance and it's
ignorance to think that you can go and
you know there's a
when it comes to the economy right when
you start trying to dictate when you
start having a centralized economy it's
you cannot pull it off you can't do it
you can't pull off a centralized economy
that's why communism doesn't work you
have to let the free market kind of do
its thing
so if you think if you if you if we know
that you can't control an economy which
is a finite thing and a controllable
thing in some
in some feasible way and we can't
control it but at least you can
understand what it is but now we think
we're going to take a bunch of millions
of people and predict how they're going
to respond and predict what the
secondary tertiary effects are going to
be with what they think and how they're
going to behave like that's completely
insane to think that
we we think we are going to control the
future with other people we think we
understand what they're doing we we
can't
so we have to start behaving in a way
that we
we utilize our power
to
make to attempt to influence but we
can't think to ourselves that the things
are going to play out the way we think
they're going to play out because they
don't
they don't they couldn't even figure out
these two freaking guys in afghanistan
one of them's from england
hey everyone's going to listen this guy
meanwhile there's a local here that's
been running for years and we think
this other guy's going to fly in from
england he speaks english he must be
smart everyone's going to listen to him
no
no and then you just play that out over
and over and over again in a bunch of
different scenarios in iraq and in
afghanistan and in iraq and that's what
you end up with so that's why i i'm
so happy that guys like you are stepping
up people that understand that we don't
understand right people that understand
that we can't control everything people
understand that the enemy gets a vote
the civilians get to vote like all those
things come into play
and we run around like we can figure it
all out nothing is two plus two equals
four right it's always an equation with
hundreds if not thousands of variables
and anytime you change one variable
to get the continued result you're gonna
have to change every variable or many of
them right and americans we
a couple are you know that arrogance
right so what does i always say
arrogance is ignorance and cockiness
combined
and and lord knows we are a lot of
ignorance and then you've got the
cockiness
and we think we really think that people
want 5g or 4g or 3g or whatever it was
10 years ago they want that but you've
got this culture that no one wants to
bother to understand who understands the
culture of the afghanis who understands
the culture
of the yazidi in northern iraq or the
kurds in very north iraq or the shia in
southeastern who understands this stuff
the guy on the ground